AS WE GO TO
OUR NEXT GAME, I, BIO-BOT.
THE STANDARD TWITTER BIO THESE
DAYS USUALLY TENDS TO BE LIKE
"THING, THING AND THEN KOOKY
THIRD THING."
IT IS SUCH A PREDICTABLE
FORMULA THAT SPAM BOTS HAVE
FIGURED IT OUT. NOW THEY JUST
GRAB PHOTOS OF UNSUSPECTING
PEOPLE AND JUST PAIR THEM WITH
MECHANICALLY CONSTRUCTED NAMES
LIKE THIS NONPERSON, JORDAN
JIANG, WHO APPARENTLY IS
A MEDITATOR, A SPIRITUALITY
NINJA AND A DOORMAN.
I THINK MEDITATOR WOULD MAKE A
BAD DOORMAN.
THIS IS WHEN COMPUTERS
BECOME SELF-AWARE. IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE THROUGH THE
MILITARY; IT IS GOING TO BE
(BLEEP)ING SPAM BOTS. THEY ARE
GONNA BECOME SELF-AWARE
AND DROWN US OUT WITH PROMOTIONS
FOR ROLEXS AND BIG DICK PILLS.
THEN THEY'LL START PLAYING
HASHTAG WARS AND THEN IT'S ALL
OVER. SO COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA
SHOW YOU A PHOTO, AND I WANT YOU
TO GIVE ME THAT SPAM BOT'S
TWITTER BIO.
I'M GONNA START THE CLOCK NOW.
>> FIRST UP, KRIMBERLY KIMPSON,
A REAL PERSON. MATT WALSH.
>> MOM, WOLF, SIDE OF GAUC.
>> JACK MCBRAYER, POLE STOLSON.
>> HUNTING ENTHUSIAST,
SIGHTSEER, SMALL WEINER.
>> NEXT ONE, MICHAEL MCGRICHAEL.
>> BANKER, DICK PILLS 50% OFF,
VIRUS SCAN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, MY FAVORITE, KENNEDICT
BUMBERBATCH. JACK MCBRAYER.
>> A PHILOSOPHER, PLUMBER,
BEAUTIFUL LATINA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JONTIFER JERALDO.
>> MILK LOVER, POOP SOLDIER,
RACIST.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ROB RIGGLE.
>> FRIES, COLESLAW AND A SMALL
GARDEN SALAD.
>> Chris: YES.
ALL OF THOSE, ALL OF THOSE
THINGS, POINTS.
NEXT ONE, STU FRENCHERT.
>> JONAS BROTHER, BLUE CHEESE,
BALDWIN BROTHER.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
LAST ONE, DESIREE
D'ANGELO-SMITH.
>> OH, YES.
CATHERINE THE GREAT AFICIONADO.
FATHER OF 43.
AND A GLUE PROTESTER.
>> Chris: YES -- AMAZING.
WE HAVE NOT THAT HAD ONE GOOD
CATHERINE THE GREAT
HORSE[BLEEP]ING JOKE ON THIS
SHOW BEFORE.